hey guys welcome to DLM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel and in this video we're gonna
share ten tips with you guys on how to
be more photogenic. now I brought in
fresh pepper. he's a model and a youtuber
as well and he's gonna share it with you
guys. so let's not waste any more time.
let's get into the video fresh take it
over Thank You Daniel for the
introduction I'm very honored to be here
to share some of my contents with your
audience so I definitely want to thank you
for that opportunity. for those of you
guys who don't know my name is Francis
polo I've been modeling for over 15
years
I go by fresh pepper on YouTube so feel
free to come to my channel and if you
like what you see subscribe. alright guys
so today what I want to do is I want to
give you guys 10 tips on how you can
become more photogenic. I get people
asking me all the time in my inbox like hey
you know I really want to be a model but
I just don't feel confidence I just feel
like I don't look good in pictures I
don't know how to find my right angles
and whatnot but I put together ten
things you can do that would instantly
improve the way you look
alright guys so the very first thing you
could do to become more photogenic is to
work on your cheekbones now I know a lot
of people are saying oh but don't you
have to be born with great cheekbones or
cheekbones is something genetic.
not everybody's born with that but
here's the thing. if you trim down your
body fat percentage your cheekbones are
gonna pop and when your cheekbones pop
your facial features looks more chiseled
you look more symmetrical
you look more enticing and more
appealing on camera so that makes you
more photogenic. now I've made a video on
my channel on how you can enhance your
cheekbones there's several tricks and
tips that you can do so if you do that
you definitely see much more
improvements in the definition of your
cheekbones. the second thing you can do
to look more photogenic is to groom
daniel makes a lot of great content on
grooming. so you know if you
guys haven't seen all his videos make
sure you check those out. grooming is
very important taking care of your hair
making your hair look shiny and nice
very neat. taking care of your nails. your
nails is very important because when
you're doing a photo shoots
what could ruin your pictures is having
dirty nails in the photos because people
do zoom in so you definitely wanna have
clean and well-maintained nails. your
skin care is also very important. so you
want to make sure you have a nice even
skin tone. I have tons of contents around
that so definitely grooming yourself and
taking care of your appearance would
definitely make you look more photogenic.
the third thing you can do is to improve
your skin tone. improve your skin tone
improve the evenness of it the balance
the shine all of that. you want to improve
that by taking care of your skin. taking
vitamins making sure you're working out.
using the right facial products
eating healthy, drinking a lot of water.
I've made a video about this 10 tips so
you can do to improve your skin. feel
free to check that out on my channel as
well but definitely taking care of your
skin is important and that will make you
look a lot better in pictures and it
will definitely make the photographers
like working with you because that's
less retouching that they have to do on
your skin. the fourth thing you can do is
to improve your posture and look taller
in pictures because let's face it taller
people are just generally more
attractive if you look tall in pictures
you're definitely going to be more photogenic compared to
if you look shorter. Daniel has a really
great video on how you can actually grow
taller by improving your posture so make
sure you guys check that out as well. the
next thing you can do is to find your
angles. now I know you hear this term a
lot find your angles work your angles
what people don't know what that means
what that means is because everybody's
face is structured differently your
cheekbones and the symmetry of you face
is all structured differently so the
light hits your face from different
angles and it makes you look different.
so as you know in basic photography or
basic painting lights shapes and
structures. so the way the light falls on
your face can make your face look more
round more chiseled more balanced
more square whatever. so you want to find
what works best for you. one thing that I
like to do when I'm trying to find my
right angle is that I take out my cell
phone and I put it in selfie mode and I
just kind of like lift it up and go
around in a 360 motion and when I do
that I can kind of see how the light is
falling on my face and then from that
way I can tell which angle and what side
profile looks better for the lighting
situation. next thing you can do is to
smile and if you don't have a great
smile that's fine
you can also smize. now I've made a video
about this so make sure you check that
out if you want more information on that.
smiling or smizing definitely helps
improve how photogenic you look in
pictures. it makes you more approachable
and more likeable and it just keeps the
audience looking at your pictures a
little bit longer because of that smile.
next thing you can do to become more
photogenic is to have some personal
style some swag some confidence right so
personal style is very important in the
fashion industry and in terms of
definitely looking good in front of the
camera. now if you feel like you don't
have personal style you feel like your
fashion game isn't very strong one thing
you can do is just buy a nice
form-fitted dress suits and just wear
that. definitely wearing a dress suit
makes you look more GQ makes you look
smart confidence approachable all of
that makes you more photogenic so put it
on. a formal fitted suit can definitely
go a long way and it definitely
compensates for a lot of the other
things that you might not have. the next
thing you can do to become more
photogenic is to wear colors that
compliments your skin tone. so for
example I have a darker skin tone so I
like to have more contrast. sometimes you
see me wearing green too
it makes my dark skin tone pop out a
little bit more. so just find those
colors that works for your skin tone it
makes you pop out a little bit more. the
next trick you could try to instantly be
more photogenic is to take Visine and
put a couple of drops in your eyes
before a photo shoot. now what that's
gonna do for you is that it's gonna take
away the redness of your eyes it's gonna
make your eyes white and brighter. not
only that, it's gonna give your eyes a
little bit of a sparkle so you look more
approachable more attention-grabbing and
definitely more photogenic. the next
thing you can do to be instantly more
photogenic in pictures is to do
something with your hands because a lot
of times you see models who are just
starting out they're not very
comfortable posing. so often when they
get in front of the camera they stiffen
up and then all of a sudden it feels
like your your arms are just you know
useless limbs and you don't know what to
do with it so I have a video on how to
pose for pictures and in this video I
take you through some of the things that
you can do with your hands and your legs
and all of that just kind of creating
angles and creating balance so
definitely knowing what to do with your
hands and what to do with the rest of
your body while you're posing could
definitely make you a lot more
photogenic. alright guys so those are my
tips on how you can become more
photogenic if you guys like this video
feel free to hit us with a thumbs up and
don't forget I make weekly videos on how
you can become a more professional model
and an actor so feel free to come back
and check out my channel and if you like
it subscribe. alright Daniel its back to
you. thanks fresh that was really good
thank you for those 10 tips. now guys if
you like the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and click the notification
belt so you won't miss any new videos
and that's it
cheers guys